our correspondent Bill maluan uh live at
B in the border at Eagle Pass Texas hi
Bill what are you seeing there
today and Martha good afternoon to you
it's pretty quiet out here but what
we're learning is the uh federal
government is going after the state of
Texas once again for trying to secure
its own border the feds are suing Texas
over its new border security law called
sb4 they want it blocked and they are
saying it's unconstitutional here is an
excerpt from the doj's lawsuit it says
in part quote Texas cannot run its own
immigration system its efforts through S
sp4 intrude on the federal government's
exclusive authority to regulate the
entry and removal of non-citizens
frustrate the United States immigration
operations and proceedings and interfere
with us Foreign Relations sb4 is invalid
and must be enjoined well House
Republicans were here in Eagle Pass
yesterday and they are promising Texas
there is help on the horizon take a
listen every state and city in this
country is a border state but I want to
say a special thank you and salute to
Texas you have borne the brunt of this
and we we will not let you down
accountability is coming I
promise and then take a look at this
video our team shot in lukeville Arizona
yesterday afternoon more mass illegal
Crossings of predominantly African men
coming in Sagal Guinea Mali Liberia some
of the countries we've encountered uh we
also ran into a man from Guinea who was
on the other side of the Border wall and
was begging border patrol to let him
come through a breach and for some
reason he had a New York state ID card
in his hand that he was holding take a
listen to this
exchange please please please my brother
please don't let me here please may
Allah help
you and you can see that ID card in his
hand right there we don't have any more
information on how he had it why he had
it or if it's real or fake but you can
see he was standing there near a breach
of in the border wall with a group of
other men who were hoping to come in
we're told that man did later across
illegally in a different area and back
out here live Martha we're just learning
moments ago uh New York city mayor Eric
Adams has announced he is suing 17
charter bus companies involved in Texas
governor Greg Abbott's busing operation
of migrants from here in Texas to New
York City mayor Adam saying he is
seeking to recoup $700 million in
incurred costs for providing shelter and
services to the migrants once they're
dropped off in New York city so it's a
sanctuary City that isn't happy they're
having to do the sanctuary par we'll
send it back to you fascinating
everybody's suing everybody the
Department of Justice against the state
of Texas and mayor Eric Adams against
bus companies uh trying to stop them
from delivering people in his region
Bill thank you very much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else